ten days after a government decided to
partly ease the curfew in Iraq the rate
of covert 19 infections is rising with
more than 1,800 new cases recorded a day
the last few days saw an unprecedented
increase in the number of new infections
which suggests that the situation in
Iraq is about to reach its peak
officials and doctors have warned that
Iraq's health system is nearing collapse
filled clinics are being opened to cope
with the growing number of patients a
charity helped set up this temporary
hospital at Baghdad International Fair
Iraq's health sector has been
chronically underfunded and the latest
fiscal crisis has made mattress even
worse doctors say they lack medical
supplies including protective gear and
according to the Ministry of Health
hundreds have fallen sick but on the
streets of Baghdad life appears to go on
as normal many Iraqis don't observe
social distancing or the requirement to
wear masks in public some blame the
government for not doing more to help
Iraqis comply with government measures
the Health Ministry is not making too
much effort they didn't provide people
with gloves or masks there are people
you don't have any money to afford them
there's almost no government support for
small businesses hit hard by the
pandemic and while many shop owners say
they can't afford to stay home this
juice bar owner wants a full lockdown
to contain the virus but one that is
enforced equally and without favor to
fight a corona we demand the government
to impose a proper curfew for 15 days
closed all the roads
don't let anyone go out at the moment
everyone has a special badge and they go
around as they wish or they pretend
they're getting medicine while they have
no disease despite the increase in cases
the government appears to want to ease
travel restrictions preparations are
underway at Baghdad International
Airport to resume flights
in the beginning we will open up
internal flights and hopefully once we
can deal with the virus we will open up
the entire airspace when the passengers
depart we will examine their
temperatures and we will sterilize them
in special tunnels before they enter the
halls reopening would give a boost to
Iraq's ailing economy but many fear it
could further deepen a health crisis
that the government is struggling to
contain simona 14 al jazeera baghdad